Зарплата українських військовослужбовців залежить від посади,
військового звання, терміну і місця служби.
Скільки вони заробляють зараз?
З 2018 року посадові оклади військових
прив'язали до прожиткового мінімуму,
і суми збільшилися у кілька разів.
Приміром, посадовий оклад стрільця нині складає 2700 гривень
командира танка - понад 3 тисячі
а командира бригади - 7 тисяч.
Зміни торкнулися йокладів завійськовим званням.
Так, приміром, розмір окладу зазвання "солдат"
збільшився до560гривень,
а "майор" - до1420гривень.
Військовослужбовці отримують винагороду
за безпосередню участь у бойових діях на Сході України,
при цьому сума залежить від місця виконання завдань.
За даними Міноборони, якщо боєць перебуває на лінії бойового зіткнення,
це 10 тисяч гривень
в інших районах - 4 з половиною
Крім того, військові можуть додатково
отримати виплати за знищену ворожу техніку.
Приміром, за підбитий або захоплений військовий автомобіль,
за даними ЗМІ, платять трохи більше 12 тисяч ,
БТР або танк коштують понад 40 тисяч,
натомість найбільше можуть дати за корабель першого рангу -
понад 243 тисячі гривень.
Також військові мають отримувати тисячу гривень на добу
за безпосередню участь у бойових діях,
а також від 60 до 365 тисяч гривень
за успішне виконання завдання у складі підрозділу.
Серед інших додаткових виплат -
надбавка завислугу років урозмірі до50%
від звання іпосадового окладу,
надбавка зароботу зтаємними документами,
а також надбавка заособливості військової служби.
Крім того, існують окремі винагороди забойове чергування,
стрибки зпарашутом і водолазні роботи.